the man Dawes has been together for 10
years now
[Music]
but frontman tailor Goldsmith had modest
expectations in the beginning I was
pretty realistic about what it meant and
at that time like in 2009 to be like a
folk rock band with slow songs with lots
of words and acoustic guitars and
harmonies I wasn't delusional about like
how far we could take things you weren't
thinking you were gonna be a rock star
no Dawes which includes Goldsmith's
brother Griffin on drums bassist Wiley
Gilbert and keyboardist Lee party knee
has built a devoted audience without a
massive breakout album or a huge radio
hit
[Music]
that's never been the case with us it's
always been like little by little fan by
fan some of the songs on their sixth
album passwords are love songs a
goldsmith is engaged to singer and
actress Mandy Moore star of the hit TV
series this is us it's a very modern
romance Instagram Instagram yeah she
posted a picture of like a song we were
releasing like I'm excited for this
record for the summer right and I was
like whoa beautiful woman Mandy Moore is
like posting about our band and so if
you ever want to come to a show
here's my email and honestly like was
there a part of me that was like maybe
you like want to flirt with me someday
and like of course there's that funny
voice but it's like I wasn't actually
like you weren't expecting you know I
was like that was something of her to
say here's our record but you had to
send the record yeah yeah they'll be
married this year but first they had a
mountain to climb Mount Kilimanjaro and
how are you as a mountain climber hey I
was impressed with myself that I could
handle it as long as I could I just had
marched up there and didn't complain
they made their ascent this past spring
well we were driving on the bus looking
at the mountain for the first time she
got emotional should I cry she's like
this it's like I'm like I'm humbled and
I'm I you know it's sign and it's it was
a spiritual moment more or less and I
was like sitting there looking at her
like I'm not having that so as we got
there I had this sort of like find out
what that meant to me and find out where
that respect was coming from where that
fear of nature was coming from did you
get to the top yeah all the way to the
top and how did that feel it was wild
and you feel drunk like you you keep
your balance is kind of off because
you're 19,000 feet in this guy Wow
so musically do you have any mountains
left musically the dream is to be able
to say I'm in that band Dawson here the
20 arms are we mates who those who ever
get that far but that's six is pretty
good yeah
six is great yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]